welcome to the show thanks for being
here thanks for watching a lot to talk
about today it's gonna be a bitty be a
pretty busy show but before we get to
any of that you know double chin sagging
jaw lines turkey necks they are a real
problem for a lot of people that is
until now introducing the new gen you
cell jawline treatment formulated with
MDL technology and genu genu cells
amazing Mother's Day sale has been
extended so just because we're past
Mother's Day doesn't mean you can't take
advantage of the sale it's been extended
for a limited time no Robin s from
Lubbock Texas wrote I put that jawline
cream on my neck like two or three days
ago it's the best my neck has looked in
over 20 years several people told me my
face looks young so that's that's what
you're getting here you could get
expensive or harsh treatments to make
you look younger but why would you do
that for a limited time you can get the
genu cell jawline treatment absolutely
free when you order the classic Jen you
sell for eye bags and puffiness and with
it's instant effects you can see results
in the first 12 hours that's guaranteed
or you get your money back alright so go
to Jen you sell calm that's Jen you sell
calm GE n you CL calm and enter matte 25
at checkout for my special discount it's
a surprise premium gift with all orders
that you get as well so visit Jen you
sell calm that's Jen you sell calm and
enter matte 25 at checkout
okay as I or as the daily wire reported
I should say this week NPR has issued
what they're calling a guidance reminder
which is an appropriately Orwellian
phrase to to describe inappropriate you
know an Orwellian thing that they're
doing and in the guidance reminder what
it is is it's instructing journalists on
which words and phrases they should
avoid and which they should employ when
reporting on the abortion issue so NPR
just to give you an eye to go through
their whole memo that they released on
this but just to go the highlights here
NPR suggests that reporters avoid
writing or saying
partial-birth abortion and instead of
partial birth abortion they say that you
should use the term intact dilation and
in Streck extraction intact dilation and
extraction is the term you should use
set of partial birth abortion they say
don't use the term abortion clinic
instead medical or health clinic that
performs abortion a little bit of a
mouthful but there you go it's
recommended that you don't refer to
abortion doctors instead they say well
you could talk about someone a doctor
who operates clinics where abortions are
performed of course it says don't use
unborn baby that's a big no-no because
NPR says it's not a baby until it's born
and before that it's a fetus or use the
word fetus you must not under any
circumstance refer to pro-lifers no no
they are abortion rights opponents not
pro-lifers journalists are even
cautioned against using a phrase like
fetal heartbeat which is a which is a a
medical phrase even has fetus in there
you'd think they'd like that fetal
heartbeat medical phrase they say don't
use fetal heartbeat it's got too much
baggage you know might it might make
someone think of a fetus as a living
person and we wouldn't want that right
now you don't know you don't want to
talk about that the point at every turn
here is to utilize language that will
make abortion seem as clinical and
sanitized as possible while making pro
lifers seem as crazy as possible that's
the idea now while I respect NPR's
steadfast commitment to partisanship and
distortion and their their loyal
submission to the abortion Lobby I tend
to think that these code words only make
the abortion conversation more confusing
which of course is precisely the goal
that's obviously I know that's what
they're trying to do promo boards always
want to talk about abortion in a way
that will not encourage anyone to
actually think about abortion they don't
want you to they want to put that as a
side even though you're talking about
this issue they want to make the issue
you're discussing as a side thing
de-emphasize it
as much as they can as a pro-lifer
myself but more importantly as someone
who values honesty and clarity I take
the opposite approach if we're gonna
talk about killing babies we should be
straightforward and frank about it we
should use terms and phrases that make
it clear what we're talking about
just like we should be doing that in any
conversation you should be using
language that clearly conveys the
meaning of what you're trying to say so
I thought I would offer kind of an
answer to their guidance reminder with
my own guidance reminder of ideas of you
know phrases and in terms that we could
use in place of some of the more
commonly used ones so let me go through
a few of these number one fetus simply
means offspring in Latin if you're going
to insist on fetus you may as well
insist on in in Japan Japanese for
infant is a catch an which I knew off
the top of my head I didn't have to look
that up I'm fluent in Japanese in case
you didn't know that's a lie
so infant in Japanese is a catch at it
be like if you said no no no they're not
babies they're a catch and it's okay
it's the same thing as just using a
different language in your effort to
avoid using the word baby you're still
using the word baby you're just it's as
I said a different languages all but
even the word baby or unborn baby might
not be the best choice and I think maybe
people just tune out that phrase now
especially pro-abortion people which is
why here's my first guidance reminder I
have been advocating maybe as you've
heard before I have been advocating that
we refer to the unborn as undocumented
infants because after all the only
difference between an infant in the womb
and an infant outside of the womb is
that the former lacks a birth
certificate that's really the only
difference so they are literally
undocumented infants number two intact
dilation and extraction sounds like
something that your dentist might do
which obviously is the point it's how
supposed to sound but it's probably not
an appropriate term to use to describe a
procedure where a fully developed viable
and living infant child is pulled from
the womb feet first
until just his head remains in the birth
canal and then he's executed via suction
tube to the back of the skull and his
brains are sucked out of his head while
he's still alive okay that's what a
that's what a partial birth abortion is
that's how it's conducted that's I mean
making it up or exaggerating in the
slightest that is literally how they do
it
so intact dilation and extraction no you
know we need something that communicates
the horror of it because it is a
horrible thing partial birth abortion
doesn't quite capture it either I don't
think so
in place of both of those euphemism I
would suggest cervical infanticide
partial birth abortion is literally the
killing of an infant as it passes
through the cervix so cervical
infanticide that would be my idea number
three reproductive rights is a misnomer
nobody is challenging a woman's right to
reproduce reproduction has nothing to do
with this debate at all I will say it
again reproduction has nothing to do
with this debate it is irrelevant
scientifically speaking reproduction
occurs at conception now that's a
scientific fact you don't have we don't
have to now it's also scientific fact
that life begins at conception but we
can even put that to the side whatever
whatever you think life begins there's
no doubt that reproduction happens at
conception that is the that is the
moment of reproduction I've been in the
hospital for the births of three
children and I don't remember anyone
shouting and saying look she's
reproducing nobody says that because
that's not when reproduction happens it
doesn't happen as the baby emerges from
the birth canal that's because birth and
reproduction are not the same a woman
who avoids conception entirely either
through abstinence or birth control has
failed to reproduce and as such has
exercised her reproductive rights
by choosing to reproduce or not
reproduce that is to conceive a child or
not or to engage in the activity which
could result in conception that's where
your reproductive rights come into play
once the baby is produced reproductive
rights are guard have nothing to do with
it anymore
a woman who gets an abortion is killing
a child that's already been produced
which is why instead of you know through
abortion she's not exercising her
reproductive rights
she is extradited exercising her
parental murder rights because she is
the parent of that child and we are
saying that as the parent she has the
right to murder her own child as long as
the child is still located physically in
her body
even if he's on the way out of her body
stills almost as long as he's there we
got him on a technicality we can kill
him so that is those are parental murder
rights I think those I think that's the
term we should use a set of reproductive
rights abortion doctor number four is a
problematic term because it includes the
word doctor I agree with NPR that we
should discard that terminology which is
confusing and I think has the tendency
to obfuscate though their recommendation
for a replacement term is obviously
absurd
I would suggest the term medical
assassin that we use that instead
because this makes it clear that these
are professional professionals
ostensibly in the medical industry now
they did go to medical school they are
in that industry no way around that
but they aren't doctors because by
definition doctors treat and cure I'm
sure in fact if you were to look up the
definition of doctor in merriam-webster
you would find something like that about
how they treat and cure illness and
sickness that's what they swear to do in
Hippocratic oath abortionists do not
treat any diseases they do not cure
anyone of anything so they're not
doctors they kill that's what they do
they are assassins when when someone is
paid to kill another person you know
that's a that's a hitman or an assassin
a mercenary maybe medical mercenary I
think is better yeah I think well you
know what I'm going to
I'm gonna change my guidance for my
medical mercenary is the better one
there so that's what number five Planned
Parenthood I have a problem with with
using the phrase Planned Parenthood it's
technically the name of an actual
organization so maybe you could justify
using it but it is so ironic and so
divorced from what Planned Parenthood
actually does on a daily basis well you
think planning Parenthood you're
thinking of planning Parenthood planning
to be a parent whereas you go to Planned
Parenthood because you don't want to be
a parent anymore and so it even just
saying Planned Parenthood it feels like
we're complicit in this lie about what
Planned Parenthood does I would you know
I'm not settled on what we call it
instead maybe Margaret Sanger's killing
field could be a you know a suggestion
but I'm open to suggestion there but we
do need something other than Planned
Parenthood finally pro-choice is just a
completely ridiculous phrase as it would
seem to suggest that pro-choice people
are somehow in favor of choices
generally but as I have as I have
explained in the past being pro-choice
saying that you're pro-choice is like
saying that you're Pro shooting okay
plenty of people are pro-gun but their
opinion about the wisdom of shooting a
gun will depend entirely on why the gun
is being shot and in what context and at
what target
so everyone plenty of people are pro-gun
that's fine Pro Second Amendment nobody
would describe themselves as Pro
shooting because that's that's different
depends on where you are and what you're
doing there are plenty of times when
someone who is pro gun would be anti
shooting is I know that this is not a
good time to shoot the gun because it's
contextual choices are the same way
nobody thinks that every choice is a
good choice no one no one is in favor of
all choices no one thinks that we should
have the right to make literally any
choice we want and if that's not your
position that don't call yourself
pro-choice because there are plenty of
circumstances where you would be against
choice there
plenty of circumstances where you would
say no person shouldn't have that choice
in this particular situation so you're
not pro-choice stop using the phrase
doesn't make any sense when someone says
they are pro-choice what they really
mean is that they are Pro one particular
choice which specifically in this case
involves the direct killing of an
innocent human being who also happens to
be the child of the person making the
choice so maybe that's the phrase we
should use instead of pro-choice said of
pro-choice it's Pro one particular
choice which specifically in this case
involves a direct killing of an innocent
human being who also happens to be the
child of the person making the choice it
might be a little bit wordy but at least
it's at least it's honest so there's my
that's my guidance reminder I'll forward
that over to NPR all right let's say
Quentin Tarantino has a new movie coming
out Tarantino is obviously a talented
filmmaker I think is a little bit
overrated his last movie was awful in my
opinion and and it's hard to make his
last movie was a Western called hateful
eight it's hard to make a bad Western at
least it's hard to make a Western that I
will think is bad I I like to think I
have relatively discerning tastes when
it comes to movies but with westerns I
don't I like I like almost every Western
if you just put some dudes on up on a
horse on horses and have them shooting
bad guys out in the you know in the in
the in the desert somewhere
I'm all about it I like almost all of
those movies and yeah they all they
almost always have the same sort of plot
and everything and I think it's great I
could sit for 20 hours and just watch
western after Western my point is
Tarantino makes a Western and somehow he
manages to make a not only a bad one
that what the one that but one that's
unwatchable even for someone like me it
was way too self-indulgent among other
problems but anyway he's got this film
coming out called Once Upon a Time in
Hollywood and he was at a press
conference after the film's debut when a
feminist who had been keeping track of
the amount of time that women had been
allowed to talk in the movie or
given lines of dialogue in this movie
she decided to stand up and take him to
task watch this
Quentin you have put margot robbie a
very talented actress actor in your film
she was in the Leonardo with Leonardo in
wolf of wallstreet
i Tania this is a you know person with a
great deal of acting talent and yet you
haven't really given her many lines in
the movie and I wondered I guess that
was a deliberate choice on your part and
I just wanted to know why that was that
we don't hear her actually speaking very
much and Margo I wanted you to also
comment about being in the film in this
part well I just reject your hypotheses
I am like I said like I said earlier I I
I always look it to the character and
what the character is supposed to serve
to the story now as I said I'm not a
huge Tarantino guy but this is an
unbelievably stupid criticism especially
against Tarantino Tarantino made a movie
called Jackie Brown where which has a
female lead character named Jackie Brown
he made a two-volume action film with a
female lead
uma Thurman Kill Bill some of his most
iconic characters have been females so
it's so there are fewer females in this
one who cares feminists are you know I
was thinking about this feminists really
are like my kids in that they're
constantly whining well constantly
whining in general but especially
constantly doing this comparison where
whining like but why did you give him
more cereal than me look at other cereal
you cave if I want more cereal now
that's when you've got five-year-old
twins like I do you hear a lot of that
kind of stuff and that's why I just I I
have become less and less patient with
feminists as a parent because I already
have to deal with this exactly this kind
of whining in my house I don't want to
have to deal with it out in the world
too or when I go online but it's the
same kind of thing is just constant
compare yo you gave him more than her
that's not fair it's not fair no that
guy had had 14 minutes of dialogue and
she only had 11
this isn't fair she's Hugh briny
insufferable ah this is why people hate
feminism and and I think it's important
for feminists to realize now I'm not
saying that we hate you as a part I'm
saying feminism the ISM you need to
understand that this is why people hate
it I mean people really hate feminism
and there there's not a lot of
in-between it's either you are a
feminist yourself or you hate feminism
almost nobody has an in-between view of
it and it's just begin it's that's
becoming more and more the case because
it seems like your entire goal in life
is just to find examples where you can
make yourself the victim and then
complain about it and the problem is
that all you can ever find in America
are frivolous examples except for the
one or two really good examples of women
being or legitimate examples I should
say of women being victimized even
systematically victimized but you don't
say anything about those where for
instance women are told to shut up while
men invade their bathrooms locker rooms
and sports teams okay that is a systemic
victimization of women there's that's a
good thing to focus on now you got a
point there honey you don't say anything
about that instead you're focused on
this all right um a couple other Clips
here Michael avenatti was charged
yesterday with defrauding stormy Daniels
he apparently stole a big chunk of her
book advance hundreds of thousands of
dollars now the fact that somebody
called stormy Daniels was given hundreds
of thousands of dollars in a book
advance he is a travesty unto itself but
now avenatti might be headed to prison
for stealing some of it avenatti of
course
for a number of reasons has become a
huge embarrassment to the left to the
Democrat Party and especially to the
media and I think it could be good at
this juncture to remember how the media
once hailed avenatti as a savior of the
republic literally now the washington
free beacon has gone to the trouble to
compile this just to take a walk down
memory lane of how the media treated
avenatti up until just a couple of
months ago and this is this is gold
watch this
he's Donald Trump's worst nightmare my
god
joining us once again is Michael
avenatti let's bring in Michael avenatti
Michael avenatti Michael avenatti
Michael avenatti thank you very much
he's out there saving the country Jim
says he may be the saving of the
Republic if you are something of a folk
hero now Michael avenatti an apology
I've been saying I'm not for reading
Michael I've seen you everywhere what do
you would love to say I was wrong
brother you have a lot to say I am just
dying to hear what you think as people
all like you I'm the only person right
here Donald Trump fears more than Robert
Miller we think you guys are the tip of
the spear there's going to take down
Donald Trump
Michael avenatti is a beast okay that's
true he's a beast he's a beast he has a
bigger calling here that being a lawyer
is minimal compared to what he's doing
no one has talked tougher directly to
Donald Trump on TV than Michael avenatti
and Donald Trump is afraid to mention
his name that's fascinating Donald Trump
is terrified of Michael avenatti yeah
this proper run for his money everybody
else Michael avenatti existential threat
to the Trump presidency the Democrats
could learn something for you you are
messing with Trump a lot more than they
are he has no doubt created sheer panic
and Donald Trump's very fragile mind
Michael avenatti
laying down the law as guest co-host I'm
just really thinking about running for
president one reason why I'm taking you
seriously as a contender is because of
your presence on cable news you look at
the field of Democrats right now and I
for not each the one who stands out if
they decide they value a fighter most
just people would be foolish to
underestimate Michael avenatti I have
always said that they need a fighter
look I mean we're gonna continue to use
the media I think we've used it with
great success
all of my sexual fantasies involve
handcuffs yeah in some ways it's
low-hanging fruit to point to examples
of the media embarrassing itself but
that is pretty devastating when you see
all of that and then when you consider
well what is it about avenatti that the
media liked in the first place why did
they ever latch on to him and it goes
back to their insane delusional Trump
hatred where they just can't see past it
and avenatti was anti Trump and so they
figured they'd simply embraced him for
that reason speaking of insane last clip
I want to play for you speaking of
insane delusional Trump hatred Jeff
Daniels was was doing a news interview
yesterday and he is very concerned to
say the least about what will happen if
Trump is reelected this is what is what
he says after the election I was
surprised as some of the people you know
I said can you believe this election
they go yeah isn't it great
and you're going whoa my wife's on
Facebook and these go oh we got another
Trump er you know and it's just you
didn't see it coming
Atticus goes through this I know these
people they're good people there's
there's there's and there are reasons
why and he's an apologist he's an
enabler and I think there are people in
the Midwest between the coasts who don't
pretend who don't know anything about
who don't care about this I don't have
time for this who have to make a
decision now you have to decide whether
it like Atticus you believe that there
is still compassion decency civility
respect for others do unto others
remember that do unto others all that
stuff you guys believe in and you still
voted not for Hillary or for Trump where
are you now
because the everybody's your kids are
looking up at you're going but he lies
and and I think there are a lot of
people in the Midwest who are going it
might be enough for them we're gonna
find out if you know if the big gamble
is to go all the way to November 2020
which I agree and lose it's the end of
democracy it's the end of our democracy
it
jump is reelected can I can I say that
and I say this to both sides
I know it's fruitless I know there's no
point because it's gonna continue but
I'm gonna say it anyway can we just stop
with every single election people on
both sides saying if we lose it's the
end of democracy every election in my
lifetime there have been people
insisting that on both sides if we lose
it's the end of the market is the end of
democracy know this - no seriously no no
no I know I said it 50 times already
this time though seriously hey seriously
guys this time if we lose it really is
the end of democracy oh we lost and it
wasn't the end of democracy okay well
but in this election no no the last time
that was different this one though this
is the end of democracy if we lose okay
didn't end but no no hold on a second
this time really guys I'm this time it's
the end it is the end this time the end
and somehow people continually take this
doomsaying seriously I don't get it no I
will say if Trump wins it will not be
the end of democracy or the end of our
country if Trump loses it will not be
the end of our country it is there there
I think that there will be negative side
effects not even side effects not side
effects there will be many negative
effects profound negative effects to
having Democrats in charge of the White
House and if they seize control of the
entire government you know then I think
a lot of bad things could happen it
doesn't mean that the country is coming
to an end it's possible to communicate
your opposition to a political party or
a political candidate and to talk about
the bad things that might happen if this
or that person wins without insisting
that it's literally the apocalypse if
they win it is possible to do that and I
think we should strive strive for that
all right um let's see I said a bunch
emails I wanted to get through before
emails what other one other thing I
wanted to mention because you see
tragedy struck in our home yesterday but
dog ate one of my wife's fancy
decorative pillows and now I've told you
already about my wife's pillow obsession
and how she spends ninety thousand
dollars a year on pillows she has a
whole fleet of decorative pillows for
each new season and I've told you about
how our couch is covered in decorative
pillows that you can't you can't even
sit on the couch without being sucked
into the pillows and drowned I mean we
we have lost
we had a house cows cast a few days ago
who drowned in the pillows and
unfortunately died and we can't even
find him he bared of there under the
pillow somewhere so this is what happens
with the pillows and but just because we
have so many pillows doesn't mean that
any one particular pillow is expendable
in my wife's mind be clear about that
so yesterday I knew it was bad news when
I came downstairs being the only human
being at home and I found the dog's
standing triumphantly over a fancy
pillow that he had just ripped to shreds
I see these videos online sometimes of
dogs doing something bad and then you in
the video they look guilty right and
that's what's funny is it looks like
they know what they did was wrong might
I've never seen a look of guilt on my
dog's face there have been many
circumstances where he should have guilt
for what he's done but no he just he
looks excited about it
defiant every single time and now this
this dog does not know or appreciate
just how often I cover for him if he
eats a kid's toy or a kid's stuffed
animal which he does all the time then
what I'll do is I'll throw the thing
away so the kids won't notice because
everyone knows about little kid the
thing about little kids is if they can
have a toy and then forget about it
never play they could have a toy forget
about it not play with it for three
years never see it again they won't
remember but if if after three years
they stumble across it and it's broken
or they see their sibling playing with
it all of a sudden now that toy is the
most important thing in the world to
them so I can avoid that just by they
dog destroy something I throw it away
they never know the dogs probably eaten
half of their toys don't tell them
they're not aware of it nobody knows
that but
it's a secret not anymore I just throw
all the stuff away I can't do that with
my wife stuff I tried but I can because
she'll know if she has 53 pillows laid
out on the couch and she walks by the
couch and there's only 52 on that couch
she's gonna stop and say wait a second
why is there only 52 couch pillows on
the couch what have you done with the
fifty-third pillow where's the
fifty-third pillow that's the way it
goes so I knew that wouldn't work so I I
did the the only thing that the only
other alternative was for me to run away
and what I do is I just left the hell
because my wife wasn't home I left the
house and I just left the door I said
this is for you you got to deal with
this buddy this is on you and I left the
house the reason why I did that is
because I'm a coward but number two
because this is what happens and this is
really the the serious thing I wanted to
discuss this is what happens with with
men in any house where there's a woman a
man and a dog what ends up happens is
that this is it's a mystery it's
mysterious and I'm hoping maybe a female
viewer or listener can explain this to
me what happens is that whatever the dog
does the man gets blamed for it I don't
understand why but that's the way it
works so I could be upstairs and my wife
would storm in and say you know that you
know the dog need the dog just pooped on
the rug
how could you let this happen I say how
how what me I didn't do it and so I
didn't conspire with the dog and tell me
hey you know hey buddy you know it would
be really funny go poop on it go poop on
the rug yeah go do it go do a poop poop
I can't I admit that if I could get him
to poop on command on the rug I probably
have him do it every once in a while
just because it's funny but I can't so
it's not my fault yet it happens and
this is it's not I'm not the only
household this is a this is a thing
where men get blamed for what dogs do I
don't understand it it gets even weirder
when you consider that we have a cat
also and the cat is not nearly as
annoying or destructive but sometimes
she can be and if she does something
like vomits on the rug I don't get
blamed for that it's it's but it's so
it's not just pets it's specifically the
dog there is this
somehow where we become avatars of each
other I don't I don't get it
but that's the way it works maybe
someone can clear that up for me all
right um I'm taking a few days off so
I'll be back on Wednesday and I wanted
to get through as many of these emails
as I can before I go so let's go this is
from Amy says hi Matt I wonder if you
could address an issue that came up for
me recently last month I was on a
business trip out of town and I found
out I was experiencing like topic
pregnancy the baby had implanted into
the fallopian tube instead of the uterus
and it already died as a result I had to
have emergency surgery that night to
stop the extensive bleeding I'm grateful
to be alive but Stevan devastated to
lose my baby after trying to get
pregnant for five years in the past
couple of weeks I've had a couple people
accused me of having an abortion I'm
Catholic and a hundred percent pro-life
I know this is wrong but was shocked to
hear that that many people think of this
as an abortion note my baby was already
dead how could I abort him would you
address this issue and educate your
larger audience hi Amy first of all I'm
sorry for your loss and everything that
you went through which is traumatic and
and I'm just sorry to hear about that
the people accusing you of having an
abortion are not only wrong but they are
horrific aliy inappropriate jerks who I
hope you will ignore
henceforward I don't know who these
people were if you can I would I would
probably cut those people out of my life
saying something like that at a time
like that not that there's ever an
appropriate time but IIIi can't even
wrap my head around it though you know I
I don't know again I don't know who
those people were I decided there are
people out if they're people close to
you then that's just terrible so first
of all if you're bleeding internally
then yes you need to have a surgery
because you'll die if you don't no sane
pro-lifer thinks that a woman should
just go down with the ship as it were
and and and die for the sake of a
pregnancy that cannot possibly go to
term that's crazy we should treasure
treasure all life including our own and
a woman should value her own life also
that's the whole point that we're making
us pro-lifers it's not that a woman's
life means nothing no all life is
infinitely valuable including the
woman's life so we should throw our
lives away for nothing choosing to bleed
out during an ectopic pregnancy makes no
sense and it would be a suicidal
decision in my view and obviously I mean
you did nothing wrong at all clearly it
sounds to me like you had a DNC
procedure which yes is how they perform
abortions in the first trimester
trimester it's also what they do in the
case of miscarriages some miscarriages
if the material from the pregnancy for
lack of a better term is still inside
the mother in that case they'll do a D
and C to avoid infections or any other
terrible result it's not an abortion no
one is being killed in this procedure
this is it's a legitimate medical
procedure so again those people are
wrong they're idiots they're horribly
inappropriate and I hope you will ignore
them and I'm sorry again for everything
you went through this from err
says thank you for your show I noticed a
few days ago that during your whole show
you were out of focus but your bookshelf
in the back was in focus was that some
kind of artistic choice yeah
yeah let's go with that it was a it was
an artistic choice I was trying to make
a point about how something I was making
some kind of artistic point I'll let you
figure out what the point was but the
main point is that it's it was not that
I'm a massive massive idiot that was not
the reason for that it was it was
something else from Graham says hi Matt
what do you have against vegans short
and sweet question I wouldn't say I have
anything against vegans vegans can be
vegans if they want I have no problem
with that I just think number one
arguably it's immoral to not eat steak
arguably I think you could make that
argument I'm not saying I make that
argument but you could make the argument
I have had steaks that were so good that
I think I had a moral duty to eat them
and if you're offered a steak that good
I think maybe it's you you're obligated
to say yes possibly
okay maybe perhaps slightly more
convincingly I just think the vegan
ethic is a little incoherent because it
seems to me that if if we are superior
to animals if we have authority over
them if we take precedence over them
which is what I believe then obviously
it is justifiable to consume them we
shouldn't we shouldn't kill them for no
reason we shouldn't abuse them but it
can be justified to eat them alright but
if we're not superior if we are equal to
animals if we're no better than them
which is what I think many vegans seem
to believe then we can't be expected to
act any differently right and we have
just as much a right to eat meat as they
do animals eat meat oh I can't wait if
we're just like them and vegans like to
say well we're animals too okay well
what do animals do look at how animals
treat each other why why should we be
held to a higher standard it seems to me
that if you're holding us to a higher
standard then you're saying that we were
superior but if we're superior then I
think that goes back around to we can
eat steak so either way it leads back to
eating steak this is from Christian says
oh great bearded one I believe I know
why everyone was so upset about the
ending of Game
Thrones and that is that the writers
gave the iron throne to the wrong person
every viewer in their heart of hearts
knows that in fact Matt Walsh has the
only just claim to any throne under
heaven fictional or not and the people
are disgusted that these writers had the
audacity to deny your basic right we all
await today when you rise to power and
bring justice upon these foolish writers
on another note I know that you have
said that you do not find Pascal's wager
to be a convincing argument for faith
because anyone convinced to belief by it
will almost certainly lack sincerity
however I believe that this argument
would better be suited for abortion if
we're wrong we have inconvenienced
people by our pro-life laws and efforts
but if they are wrong they have
participated in the largest ongoing
genocide I don't think this is our best
argument but might be effective on
someone who remains unconvinced of our
position I'd love to hear what you think
and keep up the good work first of all
you may think you can avoid the
executioner by flattering me and you're
right so well done
as for Pascal's wager related to
abortion I think that's an excellent
point actually yeah when it comes to
faith itself
I don't think Pascal's wager is a good
argument and I don't think it will get
you there
but I do think that that sort of
approach does make sense in other
contexts so it's kind of like okay so I
so so even if we don't know whether the
being in the womb is a person or not
even though we do know but let's say we
don't doesn't it make sense to treat it
like it is
if pro-lifers are wrong then as you said
we've we have we have what have we done
if we're wrong we have accidentally
treated a non person with more respect
than it was due okay that's we've
accidentally given too much respect to
this entity but if pro-abortion people
are wrong then we have murdered 60
million people which is the more
horrifying possibility so yeah if you're
on the fence it seems like wouldn't you
err on the side of not killing people
yeah I've made a similar argument about
the idea that the unborn child is a
potential person there are some people
who say it's not a person as a potential
person and my point is similar that okay
let's say that it is a potential person
let's say it's not a
person it's a potential person again we
that's not the case it is a person but
for the sake of argument but then why
does it follow how does it follow that
we can then kill the potential person
would you not treat why wouldn't you
treat a potential person as an
extraordinarily valuable thing it's a
potential person for goodness sakes
think about that
the analogy I've used which doesn't work
completely but it almost works doesn't
match up completely a little bit of a
crude analogy but the analogy I've used
is a lottery ticket imagine that you had
a 50 million dollar a winning lottery
ticket you're on your way to cash it at
the lottery office and you've got it in
your hand waving it around not a smart
move but let's say you do the thing you
have in your hand is just the potential
for 50 million dollars it is not itself
literally physically 50 million dollars
it is the potential of 50 million
dollars in a literal sense all it is is
a receipt but if I ran up and stole that
receipt from you and destroyed it
you would react as though I had just
destroyed 50 million dollars and I could
not make you feel any better by Sagna
and I wasn't 50 million dollars it was
just the potential of 50 million dollars
it was just a thing that was about to
become 50 million dollars but it was not
yet a fifty million dollars itself well
in that situation you would see no
distinction your response would be yeah
okay but it's basically the same it's
maybe not exactly the same but it's for
all intents and purposes you just
destroyed fifty million dollars I who I
was about to have fifty million dollars
now I don't because of you that's the
point this potential person was about to
be a person now it's not going to be
because we killed it so it's they even
if I accept that argument it still
doesn't get you - yes let's kill it this
is from Travis says Matt I agree with
you that he ate the age limit to buy
tobacco or to drink legally should not
be raised however I do disagree with you
on the idea that grown adults no longer
view drinking as cool for my experience
many adults in today's society are
simply older versions of their younger
selves their social media posts are
filled with pictures of their current
drink their conversations are routinely
centered around how they wish they
currently had a drink many of their
weekend plans are also heavily centered
around drinking excessively perhaps I
have this perception because I'm someone
who doesn't drink alcohol so therefore
finds the emphasis on alcohol by today's
society to be misplaced but I tend to
think the infatuation with alcohol
continues into adulthood and is not
experienced slowly or solely by young or
underage drinkers my perception doesn't
apply to all adults who consume alcohol
you yourself are an example this however
I believe too many adults look to
alcohol as an escape from the
responsibilities of their life I think
you're definitely correct lots of people
have an unhealthy relationship with lots
of different kinds of substances
substances alcohol included but my point
I guess is that 16 year-olds drink if a
16 year old is going to drink he is
going to do it almost entirely because
it's cool and he wants to fit in
that's almost definitely going to be the
reason with our current situation in
society and the laws being how they are
if he's gonna drink that's gonna be the
reason right he is he doesn't enjoy the
taste it's not like about relaxing with
a drink at that at the end of a hard day
you know that's not what it is it's just
he wants to it's cool and he wants to do
it and part of the reason why it's so
cool in the 16 year olds mind is because
it's forbidden with adults I think there
are a lot of unhealthy reasons to drink
and plenty of adults exhibit those
reasons or drink for those reasons
you're right I don't think there are
very many grown adults and yeah I think
that's a when we talk about grown adults
it's almost an age we have to live to
raise when we say grown adults we should
be talking about 18 plus but really I'm
talking about like 25 plus if even that
young and people like that I think there
are a few of them that do it because
it's cool and they want to brag about it
because as a grown man I mean if you go
around bragging 16 year olds will brat
they'll talk about oh man I had a beer
last night let me tell you about the
beers I had the grown adults aren't
gonna do that as much because you would
just seem like a loser for doing it it
would it would defeat the purpose
and so I think that's the dynamic that
we want to try to address we want
teenagers to learn healthy and
responsible drinking habits we and we
want we want to want to reduce the peer
pressure and I think we also want to
reduce kind of the cool factor a little
bit and I think you can accomplish all
of those things not completely but you
could help to accomplish all those
things by lowering the drinking age
letting people do it younger learn from
adults if they start to see it as I've
been talking about this I've heard from
people in other countries as I mentioned
before where you know you go to Italy or
whatever and it's not uncommon then
you'll have a family dinner you've
sitting down for dinner you have a glass
of wine and you have a 14 year olds that
are just having a little bit of wine
with dinner it's it's a normal thing not
a big deal and so I think someone like
that they're gonna be less likely to see
it as is who it's this cool mysterious
forbidden thing because for them it's
just normal and so I think that's where
we want to get as a society but instead
we're headed in the opposite direction
alright um this is from Jake's as
majestically bearded dictator I've heard
the argument among Christian
conservatives that perhaps we should
take the libertarian view of marriage
while my instinct was initially to say
that we should work toward keeping
marriage legally defying the same way it
is biblically defined I'm starting to
think that's not an option anymore
so it seems the argument is growing to
abolish marriage in the legal world
altogether ben shapiro essentially made
this argument a couple weeks ago what
are your thoughts on this is this too
much of a compromise for christians or
is this the right way to go what are
some implications i might not be
thinking of i'm slowly becoming
convinced it's the best way to go
because then at least government doesn't
have to say and what makes what it
thinks marriage is so it can't demand
that marriage is between a person and
any other person thing or things at the
same time i'm afraid it would encourage
further sexual immorality if people take
advantage of the abolition of legal
marriage
yeah i'm not
the particular argument that you're
talking about been that been proposed I
don't I'm not sure what it was so I
can't speak to that but from my
perspective I think marriage is the
foundation of human civilization it it
is what it is it serves a certain
purpose it has a certain function it is
essentially procreative it is the
fountain from which the family Springs I
don't think we can ever give up on it or
on the definition of it or on defending
it we give up a marriage we give up on
civilization that's how I see it all
right we'll do one more this is from I
don't think I got the name here I was
wondering what your personal chili
recipe was because my wife's are my high
school orchestra picnic is this weekend
and seeing is how you seem to be a
master at all things chili I thought I
might learn something from the master
himself and wow everyone there well I
can't give you my recipe because it's a
state secret but a few tips basic tips
if you're doing chili use no beans or
minimal beans I can't believe I'm even
going to say this but I think if you are
making chili for a mass audience
especially for chili novices for the
kinds of people who will be disturbed by
the lack of beans in the chili because
they don't understand what real true
real chili is then we'll be so
distracted by it that they can't even
enjoy this masterful creation then you
have given to them out of the kindness
of your heart then in that case throw a
few beans into the pot just so they'll
shut up so minimal beans number two the
only things you should use to make the
base or broth for your chili if you if
you need liquid you need to add liquid
to the chili there are only two things
you should ever use beer and beef broth
those are the only two never water never
tomato juice tomatoes I cannot stress
this enough there is no reason for
tomatoes to make an appearance in your
chili it is not a tomato soup
it's not about tomatoes number three
season season season just tons of
seasoning people is that there's an
epidemic in this country of people under
seasoning their food whatever just put
the amount of seasoning that you think
is appropriate and then do three times
that and then finally I last tip I would
say is remember that beef is the star of
the show okay again it's not about
tomatoes it's not about beans
it's not about peppers and onions and I
think nothing wrong with putting peppers
and onions in the chili but this is
about the beef and everything should be
in service to the beef everything should
bring the the mind and the heart and the
soul back to the beef while enjoying it
so always remember that we will end on
that inspirational note thanks everybody
for watching thanks for listening I'll
talk to you next week Godspeed hey
everybody I'm Andrew Clavin host of the
Andrew Clavin show you know some people
are saying that the last season of
American democracy is not as good as
some of the others when the show opened
we had characters like Thomas Jefferson
and George Washington expounding
brilliant ideas and living lives of
admirable courage and virtue now we have
a bunch of clowns doing reality TV and
yet things are going well it's kind of a
mystery we'll talk about it on the
Andrew Clavin show I'm Andrew Clavin